[Musique]
il a presque quotidienne régionale il
est télévision locale vous présente le
club des territoires toujours autour de
la question de l'énergie on va commencer
par la question des coupures
d'électricité qui inquiète les français
Emmanuel Macron a tenté de rassurer en
fustigeant les scénarios de la peur en
affirmant que la France va tenir cet
hiver mais ce sujet revenu hier au Sénat
lors de la séance de questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement on va
écouter cet échange entre le sénateur
communiste pierre ouzulia est le
ministre de l'Industrie Roland Lescure
en septembre 2020 le président de la
République célébrait la France comme le
pays des Lumières et de l'innovation et
railler ceux qui préférait le modèle
amis chez le retour à la lampe à huile
cet hiver la France des Lumières va
basculer en mode amiche et s'éclairer à
la lampe à l'huile et à la bougie
comment la septième puissance économique
mondiale est-elle plus devenir en si peu
de temps un pays en voie de
sous-développement le plan de prévention
a été extrêmement calibrée l'application
Ecowatt permet de prévenir ces
délestages bien en avant je vous le dis
et je vous le rappelle au cas où la
météo deviendrait orange ou rouge chacun
d'entre nous doit faire les efforts pour
limiter sa consommation pour éviter le
pire le meilleur c'est quand même de s'y
préparer
nous y sommes prêts nous les vitrons
est-ce que le plan de prévention est
calibré selon vous comme le dit Roland
Lescure comme vous l'a dit hier on
enlève de la séance de questions
Gouvernement sur ce sur ce sujet j'ai le
sentiment aujourd'hui qu'on a c'est
l'arroseur à rosé clairement le
gouvernement inquiété nos concitoyens en
se préparant on annonçant un certain
nombre de difficultés sur un plan
hypothétique je crois que ce qui est
derrière aujourd'hui c'est plutôt l'État
qui cherche à se couvrir de d'un certain
nombre de difficultés auxquelles on
risque d'être contrat donc j'ai quand
même très réservé sur cette
communication il est important de se
préparer je crois que dans les
territoires ça se fait la difficulté
c'est que il y a de l'assurance cher
autour de cette question et qu'il est
temps de de rassurer nos concitoyens
ensemble l'assurance politique on sort
quand même d'une période de crise
extrêmement compliquée que ce soit à la
fois la pandémie mais aussi mais aussi
la crise énergétique je crois qu'il est
la guerre en Ukraine il est temps aussi
de se poser les territoires les collect
c'était s'y préparent à ses éventuelles
coupures d'électricité
et aujourd'hui elle considère que les
les mesures ne sont pas ne sont pas
opérationnelles elles seront prévenues à
17h la veille elle préfère elle
préférerait pardon être prévenu à midi
et puis un certain nombre d'équipements
qui ne sont pas partis des mesures
d'exception je pense à tout le secteur
de de l'assainissement qui peut poser un
certain nombre de difficultés donc
clairement personne n'est prêt
aujourd'hui
Emmanuel Macron il fustige les scénarios
de la peur et pourtant hier dans sa
réponse Roland Lescure il exclut pas lui
la fermeture des écoles est-ce que du
coup le scénario de la peur est quand
même là ça ça fait partie des
inquiétudes des Français devant les
écoles fermées on est dans une situation
exceptionnelle qui a pas été anticipé je
crois que voilà on arrive on arrive à un
moment on savait qu'avec la crise
énergétique liée au conflit en Ukraine
un moment ou un autre on se rend en
difficulté donc là on est aujourd'hui on
attise les peurs de nos concitoyens
moi j'ai le sentiment qu'il faut qu'on
se prépare mais dans la sérénité et non
pas dans des scénarios des scénarios le
scénario du pire peut toujours arriver
mais je crois qu'il faut plutôt être
dans dans quelque chose d'être attentif
plutôt à ce qui va se préparer est-ce
que est-ce que politiquement parlant ça
vous paraît bien joué Jean-Baptiste de
la part du gouvernement d'annoncer en
amont un scénario en finalement misant
sur le fait qu'il n'arrivera peut-être
pas non non enfin clairement Emmanuel
Macron c'était l'homme de la start-up
nation et de la et de l'agilité on voit
bien ce sénateur communiste qui a beau
jeu de dire que la septième puissance
mondiale a basculé à basculer dans dans
le noir dans la décroissant dans un
système à niche dit-il c'est retour à la
à la lampe à huile donc effectivement on
est sur un peu un jeu de rôle entre
entre la majorité et et l'opposition
position qui a beau jeu de dénoncer ce
point est-ce que si on en est là aussi
parce que si on prévoir ces éventuels
coupures d'électricité c'est parce qu'il
y a une baisse de la production
d'énergie en France et à la voiture
d'une vingtaine de réacteurs est-ce que
du coup ça a été une erreur de vouloir
baisser la part de nucléaire et ne donne
pas investir dans l'entretien de ses
réacteurs
à titre personnel je pense que ce débat
il aurait dû se poser non pas il y a 10
ans mais il y a bien en amont voilà la
question n'a pas été tranchée de savoir
si on est aujourd'hui on est pro
nucléaires on l'est pas la difficulté
c'est qu'on se débat revient au moment
où on a de grosses difficultés dans le
pays certes le mixte aujourd'hui est une
solution mais on voit que il va mettre
du temps à se à se déployer donc là il y
a cette difficulté après
sur les sur les sur les fermetures elles
sont aussi liées à un événement qui est
la découverte de ces microfissures dans
le dans le dans le nucléaire on peut se
féliciter qu'à un moment on a fait le
choix aussi d'arrêter c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui c'est le scénario
sécurité qui s'applique quand il y a une
difficulté on arrête les réacteurs voilà
on peut aussi félicité il y a derrière
il y a la précaution
sauf qu'on arrive on arrive à un moment
où il faut aussi qu'on avance
oui le compte n'y est pas en matière
d'énergie
renouvelable les objectifs aujourd'hui
ne sont ne sont pas atteints c'est tout
l'objectif de la loi là qui en
discussion devant le devant le Parlement
qui va supprimer aussi un certain nombre
de procédures de feu vert et ça ça peut
quand même poser aussi un certain nombre
de difficultés sur le plan local parce
qu'on sait très bien que les éoliennes
suscitent moult crispation ouais c'est
une bonne réponse renouvelable qui a été
bloquée par le Sénat
sur les éoliennes et particulièrement
brillants je crois que c'est aussi
important que le voilà un moment le
Parlement saisis de cette possibilité
d'ouvrir enfin de facilité les
installations après je crois qu'il faut
pas que ça se fasse n'importe où
il faut que la concertation elle
s'organise avec avec les territoires
pour
bien anticiper les lieux et les lieux où
ils seront installés
qui inquiète il y a aussi la hausse des
prix de l'énergie pour les ménages les
entreprises et aussi les collectivités
pour les Mairies cette augmentation des
prix virent au casse-tête de nombreux
élus ne savent pas comment boucler leur
budget 2023 Samia de chier nous emmène à
Fontenay-aux-Roses dans les
Hauts-de-Seine une commune de 25000
habitants dans laquelle les dépenses
vont exploser l'an prochain
il y en a une pour chaque élève de
Fontenay-aux-Roses des polaires pour
compenser la baisse du chauffage dans
les écoles
de l'énergie la mairie a décidé de
diminuer la température des bâtiments de
la ville jusqu'ici régler à 19 degrés à
17,5 18
ce qui veut dire qu'il y a quand même
des moments où ça peut descendre un tout
petit peu en dessous
et donc pour que les enfants n'en
souffrent pas nous avons décidé d'offrir
une polaire effectivement à tous les
enfants des écoles ce qui est une
dépense
relativement modique puisque ça va nous
coûter 40000 euros et ça va selon nos
calculs nous permettent de faire selon
les tarifs probables plus de 300.000
euros d'économies
au revoir réduction des illuminations de
Noël extinction systématique des
ordinateurs la nuit ou encore lavage des
mains à l'eau froide pour boucler son
budget 2023 la mairie de
Fontenay-aux-Roses fait la chasse aux
économies mais ce n'est pas suffisant
tous les robinets avec les économies
différents et variées ou atténuation de
dépenses de toute façon on serait avec
un 2 millions à trouver quoi qu'il
arrive c'est un escape game il y a pas
de skate en fait
[Musique]
2,5 millions d'euros c'est 10% de son
budget communal un véritable casse-tête
pour ce maire obligé de présenter des
comptes à l'équilibre sous peine de voir
sa commune placée sous tutelle
financière seule solution pour trouver
des fonds augmenter la taxe foncière
mais dans une commune qui compte 43% de
logements sociaux la marge de manœuvre
est limitée
on aimerait bien d'ailleurs que nos
dirigeants perçoivent la grande
disparité des villes en fait il y a des
villes qui ont historiquement eu
beaucoup d'entreprises c'est là en
général reste à l'aise malgré tout et
souvent sont des villes qui en plus ont
un taux de change social qui est
minimale et donc finalement
on probablement une certaine marge de
monnaie financière les villes qui ont à
la fois peu d'entreprises historiquement
et qui ont un fort taux de l'agence
sociaux aujourd'hui elles ont aucune
marque de manœuvre un cas loin d'être
isolés beaucoup d'élus se demandent
aujourd'hui comment boucler leur budget
ils ont jusqu'à fin mars pour le faire
pour y arriver Fontenay-aux-Roses
pourrait bien augmenter sa taxe foncière
de 19%
. l'exemple de Fontenay-aux-Roses qui
est un exemple parlant mais qui une
situation que connaissent beaucoup de
communes comment un maire aujourd'hui
peut boucler son budget comment il peut
anticiper cette hausse des prix de
l'énergie c'est une situation que je
comprends la situation la situation du
maire de Fontenay-aux-Roses j'ai été
maire en nombre années aujourd'hui je
vois l'ensemble de des anciens des
maires que je rencontre sont dans cette
difficulté comment on va réussir à
boucler le budget avant le budget
préparé le budget de 2023 il y a le
budget 2022 aussi la clôturé
vous savez quand on est élu ce qu'on
aime c'est pouvoir c'est aussi pouvoir
prévoir prévoir savoir comment on va
organiser quel qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
pour la commune un an deux ans trois ans
et aujourd'hui l'horizon avec toutes ces
difficultés auxquelles on est contraint
en tant que en tant qu'élu local on est
sur des horizons extrêmement courts de 3
mois le sujet qui est qui est évoqué et
très compliqué parce qu'en fait on voit
que l'État à un moment à chercher à
contraindre les budgets des
collectivités avec cette obligation
d'équilibre des budgets de
fonctionnement pour pouvoir dégager des
marges pour financer de l'investissement
c'est à la fois la revalorisation du
point d'indice c'est vrai qu'on peut on
peut s'en féliciter la crise énergétique
les prix qui s'envolent et une
difficulté c'est l'inflation qui est
sous-jacente et cette difficulté de
trouver de nouvelles recettes l'état
donne un certain nombre de dotations par
contre elle ne les revalorise pas et on
voit la difficulté dans lesquelles
aujourd'hui des collectivités se
trouvent d'autant que on l'entend là
dans le reportage de Samia on pas de
centaines d'euros le mardi nous manque 2
millions et on rappelle en plus
Jean-Baptiste que une collectivité est à
l'obligation de voter un budget à
l'équilibre oui contrairement à l'état
c'est d'ailleurs souvent ce que reproche
les maires au gouvernement au
gouvernement au moment où le
gouvernement met en place des mesures
restrictives sur les finances sur les
finances communales il y a aussi une
difficulté nouvelle c'est quand même les
taux d'intérêts qui flirtaient avec zéro
et qui ont tendance à flamber avec des
conditions de prêt parfois plus
difficiles pour pour les collectivités
on accorde pas forcément des prêts à
tout à tous les coups donc elles sont
obligées de se serrer à la ceinture un
peu comme en 2014 au moment où les
dotations avaient commencé à à décliner
mais le choc est sans doute plus rude la
marche la marche plus haute parce qu'il
y a la hausse des prix de l'énergie mais
aussi la hausse des du prix des matières
premières qui pèsent à un moment de
construire un stade à une piscine ou une
ou une médiathèque donc de ce point de
vue là les finances commun sont quand
même sont quand même dans clairement
dans le rouge donc c'est ce qu'on sait
ce qu'on a vu avec ce avec ce maire il
faut renier sur chaque sur chaque ligne
budgétaire ça c'est compliqué quand on
émerve vous l'avez été Thierry cosy
c'est-à-dire on fait quoi on étudie le
budget de ligne par ligne notamment dans
la partie dépenses vous savez il y a
deux grands il y a deux grands postes et
c'est la masse salariale et le second
c'est les charges de les charges
courantes en gros c'est comment on fait
fonctionner par la enfin on chauffe les
bâtiments et donc souvent c'est il y a
une rigidité sur ces charges donc
extrêmement compliqué de de chercher des
économies donc ça se fait lingaling
c'est vrai qu'on essaye de rogner un peu
partout donc la deuxième la deuxième
possibilité c'est d'aller sur la partie
recette avec avec des des difficultés
parce qu'aujourd'hui on voit ce mer
évoque une hausse de 20%
des impôts c'est la seule c'est la seule
variable aujourd'hui d'ajustement sur
cette question de la fiscalité locale
mais pour les gens qui nous écoutent
parce que là on parle du budget des
maires bon mais ça aussi un impact sur
le quotidien des habitants ça veut dire
quoi pour le quotidien des habitants de
devoir rogner sur une partie du budget
on a moins de services publics en fait
c'est les arbitrages à faire je vous
disais il y a la partie dépenses si on
trouve pas de recette nouvelle pour
équilibrer le budget à un moment il va y
avoir des choix à faire sur sur les
services publics ils sont offerts à la
population donc pour les gens qui nous
écoutent concrètement c'est quoi
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont avoir en moins
on chauffe-moi on chauffe moins après
l'arbitrage il y a principe de libre
administration dans les collectivités
fait que c'est aussi à chaque équipe
municipale d'aller faire des choix mais
c'est ça peut être voilà sur le sur le
chauffage ça peut être aussi sur le
peut-être sur la restauration c'est
souvent c'est des choix qui sont pas
faits c'est compliqué franchement voilà
il faut chercher ligne à ligne ça peut
être aussi sur le budget culturel
malheureusement ou sportif faire des
choix ça va être aussi comment on assure
le vivre ensemble avec les associations
si on diminue obligé de diminuer les
subventions aux associations on voit que
c'est l'ensemble
de la communauté qui est qui est
impactée
qui sont très énergivores je pense en
particulier aux piscines donc une des
solutions peut être de réduire les
horaires les horaires à la piscine le
poste qui risque vraiment de bâtir le
plus de cette situation c'est
l'investissement évidemment le risque
c'est que la machine se met à l'arrêt un
maire qui était interviewé dans la
Gazette des communes nous disait en fin
de mandat généralement on coupe le ruban
bah là on va peut-être simplement poser
la première pierre et 12% des mers c'est
une étude ifope 12 % des mères envisage
de ne pas payer le sur quoi régler leurs
fournisseurs d'énergie vous les voulez
vous les comprenez ces mères oui oui je
comprends la difficulté dans laquelle
ils ont rebondir notamment sur la partie
sur la partie investissement c'est aussi
on nous demande de faire un certain
nombre de de travaux pour baisser les
factures énergétiques la difficulté
c'est que derrière on impacte aussi
chercher qui a 70% aujourd'hui de
l'investissement public et porté par les
collectivités c'est toute c'est toute
l'ensemble de l'activité économique qui
est aussi impactée par par cette
difficulté rencontre aujourd'hui des
communes et alors les maires connaissent
des difficultés mais le gouvernement
audrey a pris des mesures pour tenter
des délais collectivités locales qui
prennent de plein de fruits cette crise
énergétique oui avec ce mot d'ordre de
l'exécutif aucune collectivité ne doit
être laissée sur le bord de du chemin et
pour cela il déploie tout un attirail
tenez vous bien le filet de sécurité le
bouclier tarifaire l'amortisseur
électricité on va essayer d'y voir un
petit peu plus clair concernant le
bouclier tarifaire on sait tous ce que
c'est puisque ça concerne aussi les
particuliers mais il faut savoir qu'il
est aussi mise en place pour les
collectivités locales les plus petites
moins de 10 salariés moins de 2 millions
d'euros de recettes d'après le
gouvernement il y en aurait 30000
concernés les élus les sénateurs sont
pas forcément d'accord sur ce chiffre
c'est un plafonnement de la hausse des
prix du gaz et de l'électricité et au
1er janvier ce plafonnement passera à
15% en plus de cela on a le filet de
sécurité déployé par le gouvernement
pour les communes les départements les
régions dont la situation financière
s'est dégradée cette année c'est une
prise en charge jusqu'à 70% de la hausse
des prix de l'énergie et de
l'alimentation et jusqu'à 50 % de la
masse salariale avec la revalorisation
du point d'indice on en a parlé mais
pour cela il faut justifier de
difficultés et puis enfin vous savez
qu'en fin d'année de nombreuses communes
négocient leur contrat d'énergie à venir
et avec l'explosion du prix de
l'électricité elles sont évidemment
revues à la hausse il y a donc
l'intervention de l'amortisseur du
gouvernement ça concerne les
collectivités qui ne bénéficie pas du
bouclier dans les faits si le prix du
mégawattheure dépasse 325 euros alors
l'État prend en charge la moitié de la
facture et ce de manière automatique la
ministre la première ministre pardon a
aussi promis de simplifier l'accès à ses
aides d'où l'aspect automatique car pour
l'instant c'est une très grosse usine à
gaz et certaines collectivités renoncent
de ses aides Elisabeth borne elle a
aussi promis une augmentation de la
dotation globale de fonctionnement des
collectivités oui c'est ce que l'État
verse aux collectivité tous les ans et
cette année et ils avaient borne s'est
félicité de son augmentation écoutée
c'était au congrès de lassociation des
maires de France nous avons décidé d'une
augmentation de 320 millions d'euros de
la dotation globale de fonctionnement
une hausse de la DGF c'est une première
en 13 ans et grâce à cette décision 95%
des communes verront leur DGF se
stabiliser ou augmenter une augmentation
donc mais pas d'indexation sur
l'inflation comme le demande certains
élus sachez pour la conclusion qu'en
amendant le budget laissez notaires donc
vous faites partie on fait le choix
d'indexer la DGF sur l'inflation il faut
savoir si ça restera dans le texte final
vous avez des doutes
pour le groupe socialiste donc avec vous
malheureusement non mais ça pose quand
même des difficultés on voit quand même
cette cette
revalorisation de 330 millions
aujourd'hui et pas suffisante
il manque 800 millions en gros il aurait
fallu au moins dans la difficulté dans
lesquelles sont les collectivités
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il aurait fait
ça fait quand même 30 depuis 40 ans près
de 40 ans 1985 on a jamais eu une
inflation d'un tel niveau et donc je
pense que l'effort de la part de l'État
aurait dû être plus important on a
l'état a été capable d'accompagner
depuis six ans les entreprises je pense
que il aurait pu faire un effort un peu
plus conséquent en direction des
collectivités territoriales est-ce que
alors il y a beaucoup de dispositifs
faudrait nous les appeler mais par
exemple on entendait le maire de
Fontenay-aux-Roses dans le reportage
dire pour le filet de sécurité bon ben
nous on n'est pas éligi bien problème de
ciblage de ces aides oui un problème de
ciblage car connu d'ailleurs Elisabeth
borne lors du congrès des maires elle a
assoupli un certain nombre de de
critères de seuil on n'est pas encore à
la fin du du marathon budgétaire mais je
pense que c'est le but de quand même de
tout le monde sur tous les bandes arrivé
quand même à un dispositif équilibré le
gouvernement considère aussi que les
collectivités ne sont pas en mauvaise
santé financière et c'est vrai que ça a
été confirmé par la Cour des comptes la
plupart des collectivités ont retrouvé
leur marge de manœuvre d'avant le covid
aussi grâce au soutien du gouvernement
le gouvernement est quand même présent
aux côtés des collectivités mais sans
doute pas dans la dans l'ampleur que
souhaiterait les élus vous pouvez dire
que le gouvernement est derrière les
communes soutient ces communes les
dispositifs sont là pour pour
accompagner simplement je ne dis pas
qu'il y a pas de il y a pas de soutien
je pense qu'il est pas à la hauteur de
l'attente voilà et je pense qu'on a une
difficulté passagère l'année de 23 n'est
pas sous les meilleurs augures je crois
que l'effort aurait dû aurait dû être un
peu plus important sur dans le cas de ce
PLF 2023 et on en revient à la question
de la fiscalité locale parce que
beaucoup de mer disent que maintenant le
seul c'est la taxe foncière et se
retrouve contraindre l'augmenter oui il
se retrouve contraint pas tous
finalement il y a surtout des grandes
villes qui augmentent la taxe foncière
évidemment Paris avec cette hausse de
50% qui a défrayé la conique ces
dernières semaines mais on a aussi
Marseille on a Strasbourg on est entre
10 et 20% mais toutes les collectivités
bénéficient de fait d'une hausse en fait
de cette de cette taxe foncière parce
qu'il y a une revalorisation de ce qu'on
appelle les bases forfaitaires je vous
regarderai de vous préciser le calcul
Oriane parce que je le connais pas pour
vous cacher donc on est on est à 7%
c'est-à-dire au niveau de au niveau de
l'inflation donc quand même c'est une
façon de retrouver un petit peu
d'oxygène sauf quand on se trouve dans
des villes comme Fontenay-aux-Roses où
il y a très peu de propriétaires donc
finalement il y a très très peu de
recettes de taxes foncière et c'est tout
le problème effectivement les
collectivités n'ont plus que ce levier
là pour pour bouger un certain nombre de
curseurs
on a de grandes disparités territoriales
il y a un risque là aussi de fracture
sur ce sujet
on a aussi un gouvernement qui a
organisé la trission des finances
locales on a supprimé la taxe
d'habitation qui était un engagement de
campagne simplement
dans mon entourage dans les meilleures
que je rencontre j'entendais pas même
dans les citoyens pas une demande de
supprimer le lien entre le citoyen et la
commune la prochaine étape c'est la CPAE
sur lequel pareil le
sénatisation sur la valeur ajoutée les
entreprises sur lesquelles le Sénat est
revenu donc en fait aujourd'hui sous une
volonté aussi de décentralisée de
redonner du pouvoir aux collectivités
l'État cherche à recentraliser sur les
finances locales clairement c'est j'ai
le sentiment que demain il cherche à il
cherche à supprimer la fiscalité locale
pour donner des dotations et surtout
contrôler ce que pourra faire chaque
commune
cette question de la fiscalité locale de
comment on peut repenser fiscalité
locale oui alors vous savez vous lisez
les contributions de l'Association des
maires de France dans les années 30
c'était déjà c'était déjà le débat donc
je crains pas Claude mais comment on
fait parce que vous évidemment les
merdes demandent plus de pouvoir vous
avez le sentiment vous que l'État n'est
pas prêt à lâcher du lest sur cette
question de la fiscalité
sur la fiscalité clairement et puis
le premier à me dire est-ce qu'à la
prochaine campagne présidentielle on
n'aura pas un candidat qui va annoncer
la suppression de la taxe foncière
puisque aujourd'hui c'est plutôt comme
ça que ça passe on annonce voilà ces
engagements de campagne et puis après on
regarde les effets donc mon sentiment
c'est qu'il est temps il y a un grand
débat trans partisan pour savoir ce
qu'on veut pour nos collectivités
comment comment on les accompagne est-ce
qu'on est pour un grand pacte Girondins
plus de décentralisation l'État a quand
même transféré à déconcentré donne de
plus en plus de missions aux
collectivités et derrière on cherche à
les contraindre fiscalement donc je
pense qu'il est temps de se remettre
autour de la table tous ensemble et
qu'on est qu'on puisse qu'on puisse
avancer pour terminer Jean-Baptiste
est-ce que ça a des conséquences sur le
moral des mers alors là dans l'étude
Ifop 55% des mers disent ne pas souhaité
se représenter on sait que généralement
plus la fin du mandat approche serait
plus ce chiffre diminue bon là on est
loin de la fin du mandat du coup le
chiffre des conséquences parce que c'est
un mandat de crise évidemment avec le
covid avec avec l'inflation aujourd'hui
avec la hausse aussi des a contre les
élus constaté dans une enquête du Centre
d'études de la de la vie politique
française donc les maires ont le blues
alors c'est un petit peu comme la
fiscalité ça fait longtemps
qu'ils ont le blues aussi ça s'aggrave
parce que on se souvient ça arrive dans
le quinquennat précédent il y avait déjà
eu ce genre d'étude et on s'est rendu
compte que municipal finalement le
chiffre c'est passé que ça c'est un
mandat qui est particulièrement
compliqué moi c'est vrai que aujourd'hui
je j'admire les citoyens qui s'engagent
dans le dans les mandals locaux on est
sur un mandat extrêmement compliqué qui
a commencé le jour de l'élection par un
confinement de deux mois vous savez
quand on est quand en général on monte
on monte en puissance pendant la
campagne électorale et dans la foulée on
est élu on décline le programme et on
est parti et toute l'équipe la
difficulté c'est que là il s'est passé
quasiment deux ans dans lesquels les
équipes municipales les équipes
municipales se sont vues par visio pour
la plupart du temps et donc des
difficultés à découvrir la fonction de
de conseiller municipaux notamment pour
les pour les nouveaux je crois que la
voilà c'est
aujourd'hui ça fait quand même à 2014 on
m'entendait qu'il y aurait plus de 50 %
des mers qui se représenteraient pas ça
pas été le cas sur mesure qu'on approche
et je sens quand même qu'il y a une
tension de plus en plus extrême les
équipes sont les équipes municipales
sont quand même sur quand même assez
tendus et j'espère vraiment c'est le vœu
que j'ai aimé en cette fin d'année c'est
qui est des perspectives qui sont un peu
plus un peu plus réjouissantes pour les
pour les trois ans qui restent un monde
c'est un mandat de sobriété comme dit
Elisabeth mais de la sobriété à
l'austérité en fait il n'y a qu'un pas
et on est quand même en train de
basculer dans un modèle d'une certaine
manière décroissante qui correspond pas
au modèle des des communes qui vont
quand même massivement investi depuis
les débuts de la décentralisation il y a
maintenant 40 ans